I'm open this open H
open open
house for Sunday
School in NCC to
Sun thank you for
coming in this open
house
and now
I
introduce
teachera she will beginning and start
this open house because she is
responsible Sunday school welcome
sister to thank you all for coming
to this event in I will give you some
information about the Sunday school
and what we've been doing and you know
I think details that you are in
need to know inshal what we decided
is that I will be responsible for the
Arabic
language will be responsible for the
Quran teacher will be in charge of the
Islamic
Studies we are
me teacher and sister J and other
volunteers U teacher Samir also are
helping with the Islamic Studies as well
so I would to start with our
main goal for the Sunday
School
what we saw is that you know we
would to whatever knowledge that
the students are learning we would like
to transfer the knowledge into action
and this is what we are trying to do we
are teaching Islam but we want the
students to apply what they are learning
we are teaching Arabic and what I'm
doing actually is I'm integrating
Islamic Studies Quran and Arabic all as
one subject together to facilitate the
students understanding of the Arabic
language and to make them able to
understand and read Quran in an easy way
this is our main goal for this Sunday
school is to for our students to start
insh applying what Islam is asking us to
do we don't want this knowledge that the
students I know this I know this but I
don't do it so inal we are encouraging
the students to apply what they're
learning an example for that our
first lesson was we gave the
students we want to teach them the
manners the ad the ethics and from there
we gave them the principles
of and we are encouraging the students
every time they come to Sunday school to
apply what they've learned we always
remind them to make we always remind
them to
make we always remind them to follow
and apply what they've learning so this
is the main goal of the Sunday School
I know that your expectation is high as
well as us for us you know our
expectation is high but insh we will
work together to make this Sunday school
successful without your help it's not
going to be a successful Sunday
school there are few topics that I
would to discuss as I said for the
Arabic curriculum
inal I've been using this book and
it's actually the author is Dr
mahm MD Muhammad and it's seems that
it's American open University
publisher he is an expert in Arabic
language and if you look at the book
it's actually contains lots of
vocabulary lots of grammar but not in
a sense of a grammar grammar but you
know to help the students make
sense of what what they are reading and
learning the vocabulary and how they can
use it so this is insh T I'm using it
for the upper level we have like
different levels so I'm using it for
the upper level teacher Z who's teaching
Arabic for the younger kids she's using
something different beside this book I'm
actually using this book and it does
have the basic or the foundation for
Arabic there are lots of basic that
the students need to understand to
facilitate their understanding of Arabic
and how to use it so in I will be using
these two books beside other
resources
as you saw you know we are I'm
giving a hands out for the students I
encourage the students every time to
bring these hands out back with them
every time they come to the school and I
told them be responsible I encourag them
to bring folders with them I
encourage them not to lose these
papers so I want your help to remind
your students to remind your kids to
bring whatever hands out was giv to them
or we giving to them you know in
the previous lessons or previous
Sundays for the grouping the students
it seems that it's still challenging for
us every time we have a news students we
are trying our best we are not yet
sure about your kids level we are trying
our best we still need more time so
please be patient with with us and insh
if you have anything regarding or any
concern regarding your kids please do
not hesitate to come and talk to us this
is for the grouping and alhamdulillah we
have almost over I don't know up to
now over 880 students so we are thinking
maybe in in the future in the maybe like
a month or so in to close the
registration or to stop the
registration because as you see know
we don't have that much facility we
don't want you know to really like
have the students each classroom to be
very
crowded this is for the grouping
for the attend
please please especially for women
please
come to Sunday school we are here we
are putting the time and effort we are
working hard really to educate your k
please come on time please remind your
student to bring their
materials please you know like
tell them that you know how
important for them to be to come to
Sunday school it's really very important
so without them coming and without you
encouraging them you know it's going
to be hard so please always come on
time and encourage your students or or
your kids in to
come
inshal
I asked the students of their main
goals for coming to Sunday school and
most of them they said they want to
learn Quran and they want to read Quran
in we will make it happen will we make
it come true in if we are consistent
and are coming good time
to in this is for the Arabic
Department
after that I would in to
introduce teacher who's in charge of the
Islamic Studies and
please for those who don't know me my
name is m so teacher has already
already covered the part about the
the overall plans and goals so I will
just go stretch forward to the
Islamic Studies part and
discuss or present what plans I
have for Islamic Studies so I
basically divided the Islamic Studies
into three main or four main
parts the first part is about we
already started teer J and myself
started talking about which covers the
part
of and when I say AA it's just like
what fit their level not the I mean
it's it's really when when people say a
is really scary or I don't know so
when we say AA we just our goal is
to to have them understand what l
mean and what the Oneness mean that's
all so that's one part and I think it's
really important the second part is
on the practices so we have planed to
teach them about Salah and all like
practices that are necessarily
especially for this age and as they're
growing they should know how to pray
correctly and how to understand to
understand Z and understand all the
other practices the the third one is
which is really important at this age
so we will talk
about the manners of using bathroom
manners of sleeping manners of all
the manners in Islam that's also I think
it's very important and then the
the fourth part is the s
we will cover we started talking about
the the of the Prophet the the
stories of all prophets and then we
will start soon talking about the
prophet the life of the Prophet Muhammad
s Alam so these are the four parts that
we are focus and it's for me
it's not I know those kids go to
school and they have tons of homework so
the way I'm doing it is I don't
want to make it overwhelming to
them so I'm not giving traditional
homework you won't see them coming
with papers or anything I'm not a fan of
papers anyway so but that doesn't
mean I don't give homework I give
homework in in different forms for
example if we're doing Salah I might
create a chart for example and have them
you know Mark whenever they because
we are emphasizing to pray five
times and to pray on time so the the
task might be instead of memorizing
how many Salah in or how many
instead I as teacher pointed out
our main goal is to turn all this into
practice into real you know to
leave Islam not to just know Islam so
this is the main thing so instead of
asking them to memorize the the number
of on different Sal different prayers we
ask them to to do the prayers and to
to Mark to to watch themselves
either self ass yeah there observe
themselves self assessment and self
observation so the same is for like
the manners if for example we're
talking about
respect elderly we I might like
form another childart and ask them to
you know just by the end of the
week when when they come next time
how many times have you done something
during that past week to an
elderly or to your parent so and so on
so basically I don't want we want
them to love it to love and to want
to come back every Sunday instead of
making it overwhelming and they you
know scared them away because we know
they they they have they
already have a lot of other
responsibilities other homework and
so and if you have any
questions any ideas any you are
welcome we are open to anything
it's not yeah it's our job and
it's everyone's job and thank you very
much for bringing them and that means a
lot that means you you care about them
and I think this is the the only
resource it it might be that there
are many other resources where they can
learn about the religion but this
is a good opportunity for them to come
here and to inshallah there's
something that will help them in the
future
thank you so
much I would I would also to
introduce teacher who's in charge of the
younger group
so for coming and we hope the kids
inshah doing good here actually the kids
I'm getting for for them the from the
Quran
from and foric inshallah we are giving
them from the letters and I do have some
samples here to show you and I know some
of the kids are getting their homework
to their parents so that's a good thing
but some of them they are forgetting
them so we hope that you tell our kids
to keep in charge of that and there's
some of the examples of the Arabic
of the letters and also it's practicing
how to write the
words and also for the Islamic
Studies I am using
a book called Hadith it has some of
the very short Hadith that everyone can
understand it's about how to use
the bathroom how to wear the clothing
and stuff that and how to go to the
mid and what you say and also we are
giving them some of the
Prophet story especially Prophet
Muhammad sahu alai wasam and inshallah
we are going forward for the other thing
and if you have any question please feel
free to ask or if you have any idea we
are welcoming
anything what I would to add to
what we said couple of things I
forgot to mention that U all of us we
are deciding to teach the same ccul
which mean Islamic Studies all the
levels are getting the same topic except
you know its details you know like
some of the levels are getting harder
or you know more in details than
the others based on their level and
based on their capability on their needs
so this is what we are doing even for
Arabic we are doing kind of know we
are all doing the same thing for Arabic
Islamic Studies and for Quran we also
divided certain suras for the levels and
what we are doing is if you think
that you know your son will come
let's say that he's in Abu bakik and we
name them based on
the let's say that your son in abak
level it doesn't mean that we are going
to start from the smallest or the
shortest Surah in the Quran which
is so what we did is actually we divided
the the last 30 J into sections or
into level
and that's this is what we are doing for
the Quran what we thought is that
Quran is
Quran we want to challenge your
students we wanted to challenge your
kids and you know if your son is is
learning it's the same as if he's
learning at the end it's Quran beside
learning Quran inal we want them to
understand the meaning of the aat and
the meaning of the words and this is
insh our job that's why you know like
I'm using this book to help the student
the Arabic so the students will build
their knowledge of the vocabulary that
it's from the Quran so in this is
what we are doing in addition I would
also to talk about the
behaviors what we decided is we came up
with a system which is
we are creating this Sunnah Point
what we are doing each students is
getting this charm what we are doing is
we are encouraging your kids to start
applying and do more Sunnah and based on
that you know at the beginning of
my lesson every time I distribute this
the paper and each students will come
and you know he will say you know
I did that I made the Sunnah I was
doing that and based on that he would
get points based on these point at the
end in we are going to create a sun
store and the students based on how many
points they got they can get a prize
that you know match how many points
let's say you know a prize worth
seven points the students should have
seven points to earn that
prize so this is what we are doing so
we are trying in to make the Sunday
school you know a systemat you know
a whole system Arabic Islamic and
Quran all integrated
inshal and we would to make it
in
successful maybe some of you you don't
know me but and others they know my name
is I'm actually originally from Syria I
earned my master degree in education
from University of Phoenix I've been an
Arabic and Islamic teacher at the alhuda
school for 3 years and then I became the
principal for the last four years or the
last maybe no for four years I've been a
principal and then I I'm now I'm I'm
now not part of ala school so inshah
tal we will make it successful with your
help don't think that we can do it by
ourself okay please if you have anything
regarding Islamic
Studies here's the person teacher okay
if you have anything regarding the Quran
here's the person if you have anything
regarding Arabic it's me so please come
to me if there's anything you know like
is hard to Sol or something
please yeah for the younger kids sorry I
forget her but in come to us
what we are doing in we will have
questions if you have any question
please feel free to ask and we are in
will try our best to answer you and insh
we will start the discussion or the
question but I have some worries about
the the kids living because there is a
huge number in the class and I feel that
you don't give each and the each
person the time he needs because I think
in know in this age they need more
concentrating in especially in writing
the letters and getting to
know don't forget that they are taking
English language and Arabic language at
the same time so I think they have they
need more some more efforts in that
yes do you have plan for that yes insh
as I said insh for the students number
in the future we are going to stop the
registration and we need to focus on
those who are really
coming
for what we are thinking let's let me
talk about you know the attendance for
those if we feel that you know some
of the students are really not coming
then we read we need really to reserve
that spot for others parents or for
other students who are really willing
to put the time and effort to come to
the Sunday school so in for the number
of
students what we are doing is as you
said you know for Arabic Department
I'm giving the hands out and as I said
you know I'm giving it to the to
the three levels what we are doing is
what I'm doing is I'm trying my best to
know exactly their level and
yeah you know some of the
students some of the upper level we've
already finished the first packet but
for the younger level I couldn't finish
it just because of what you are saying I
totally understand that their needs
and it's different but in we will try to
do it and we give us certain time there
is a suggestion that you know we
felt because we felt as a faculty we
felt the same we are thinking of
extending the Sun the time of the Sunday
school and instead we're thinking Okay
so so what we are thinking is in and it
was from teacher suggestion is because
of what you are saying because of the
time we are thinking insh T to maybe
to add maybe half an hour or an
hour but we need
to yeah establish everything we need to
make sure that the students are coming
we need to make sure that you know like
those whom we need to focus on and then
they will be here every Sunday you
understand what I'm saying so it's
it's a mutual thing it's from us and
from the parents as well but in it's in
our consideration and we we I understand
that just give us you know the time
be patient I always say you know I
don't have this magic sticks okay it's
Sunday school it's only 3 hours per week
per
week we are trying our best two hours I
know two y from okay and I extended
already so I'm I'm I'm shorten it now
it's two hours
okay oh yes for volunteers
okay okay there is another thing insh I
know that you are volunteering right
sister so in this will also help us as a
teachers insh so may you may pull some
of the students and you can work with
with them one onone this is something in
that we will do it and as I said we are
still we need still time to organize
everything okay so be patient with us
any other
question have a
question possible by examp the
things the kids when the kids go up to
his home you know he will never remember
all the things example what he do in the
bathroom so if you can write it in
some paper or give it with the kid and
the parents who will work with them or
another thing another thing there
possible to post it in the website of
the mid that's me the people they will
go inside this website and the third
suggestion if there is possible to write
the schedule not for all the year let's
say for the all the month for four time
yes in the in the M website so the
people want come they know what the
student I appreciate your input and I
think it's very important
inshal insh in the future we will start
in sending messages through emails or
text messages and insh we will have do
you want to talk about that question
yeah when I said I don't give
homework it doesn't mean I don't ever
give homework or send anything home but
what I said is I'm trying to make it
attractive for them so they can come
back right so so but what I said
is I don't give them a kind of
traditional homework so for example if
I'm
teaching
the maners of using the bathroom for
example I can instead of writing
something down or giving something that
will make them feel overwhelmed I
will we'll do a project okay a
project for example that involves
drawing coloring something that kids
love and maybe the they will do a type
of decoration and hang it in in
front in the bathroom door with the like
the the I the Dua of youing the
bathroom right so when they do something
this leave me they will remember it
KS that's my my suggestion if you
give them Dua for the sleeping believe
me I will let them every day right okay
we right we we had a talk with the board
brother Ahmed jabin and he's he's on
process of making a page right from the
website on for the Sunday School there
will be a page for the Sunday school and
we will post all everything even like
newsletters the plan lesson plans
the topics everything that we do here we
will post them but I'm talking only
about the the kids not the parents like
I don't want the kids to hate the school
the the Sunday school that's that's
that's the what I'm talking about it's
not but every if you need they will will
be the website the page that will
be the resource for the parents okay and
it will have everything Us in the
website and in the Facebook this is very
important can I answer are you
happy any any other
questions that's a beautiful I have a
library from
car it's to the and they have to fix it
so please two or three person because
it's very heavy yes bring to put the
book brother for that I really
appreciate your support and in this is
also know it's going to be an
encouragement for others to support the
Sunday school I can't fix it so yes
don't worry we will help you the way
that you the way that you are helping us
we will help
you and Allah put
it as a reward for
you any other question
yes I would love to hear from the
students really yes okay in the Quran
part on that period say
name I think there should be a new
strategy of learning
quaning okay do you have an idea what do
you mean by that maybe writing it down
yourself or oh writing the ayat Yeah
okay or
the I think it's a good idea if it if it
helps you then do
it my personal thing okay